[Music]
david you are going to
relate so hard to these onions
so hard he does smell kind of funky not
for that reason
david's the opposite of that why does
onions taste so sweet when you cook them
in a soup they have a lot of sugar those
are their tears
i didn't know that when you said that i
just got like this instant
memory of eating french onion soup oh
yeah and it's so good
it's good isn't it yeah oh so you just
don't like raw and i don't like
onions ever except in french onions
because it changes the chemistry
the purple like purple onions sliced
very thinly with
lime that's my shade what about sweet
maui onion that's good too
i don't know what color is that you
don't like them in your pico de gallo i
thought it was purple you got a little
brownie mm-hmm i hate pickles
those are red onions purple ones are red
onions they call them red why don't they
[ __ ] call them red onions
huh i don't know why why are you upset
this is confusing because i'm like
there's a purple one
but then they call it red yeah why what
they don't like
maybe because the skin is red they call
purple grapes right
red grapes they don't like white i don't
know what they call the red grapes red
grapes
and the the purple ones another name but
the red grapes are pretty purple
those are the [ __ ] wine grapes and
[ __ ] all right i'm going to show you
guys this photo
and just a little like puzzle in your
brain okay
take the clues i gave you david rule
relates onion walla walla sweet seed
what do you see they're ugly on the
outside but when you get to cook them
and you get to know them they're really
really sweet there's so many layers
because his
uncle ate onions to lose weight and you
can and alive was onion
anyone around them cries how about okay
more
more
more like more like just focus on the
image
there they look like his nipples there's
a basket of onions
you're getting close is it a basket of
it you guys canceled
i can't see closer
i want to go back to what you were
saying they look like his nipples they
look like tits
well it doesn't have to be his they look
like tits right so some
people well not people they back through
some algorithms
i'm pretty [ __ ] horny but it doesn't
look like it's taken down
that's why you relate are you kidding me
that's not that don't look like pitch to
me the world is crazy man
he's getting ptsd from that are you
[ __ ] kidding me
yeah so the this one company they posted
this photo as an
ad like to advertise their walla walla
onions
and so they got a notification that it
was displaying
sexually explicit content did you have
onions in your pizza
i had my titties out if someone gets
turned on by onions that's on them
yeah the robot got 100 yeah they were
they're saying that was overtly sexual
oh verbally that's what the onion that's
the robot
these kind of look like titties no they
do not you know wine glasses
you really really really really looks
more like a butt you know wine glasses
are made
or modeled after a king's wife's breasts
oh no breast disease upside down because
that's like when they're like the nicest
that's so romantic right oh when the
titties kind of fall over
those are fantastic yeah like when
you're yeah not the champagne one i hope
no okay
that's that artistic drawing booby you
know i mean they try to be super
artistic with it
yeah like abstract abstract tits she got
abstract tits girl
look at that [ __ ] flute titties that
looks like a picasso boobie it looks
like a big champagne not champagne glass
but it looks like a
champion but it's like a smaller one oh
oh for the sherry
sure for sherry yeah they use that we
don't know why i'm for sure
what about the wine glass i literally
know nothing about wine i want to
pretend like i know
the only reason why i know that because
in in um
in amelie they use that a lot yes oh for
the apple teeth
yeah that one something like that you
like all monkey
what you like amelie what's that
what the [ __ ] the most movie oh i've
never i don't know you like
you put in a reference also oh i just
said apple teeth it's french that is
french which is
a french movie
oh jesus i actually spilled wine on the
actress that plays emily
oh really oh [ __ ] and then does she say
blue something tattoos
it was like my first day working at that
restaurant oh with all the celebs chef
perfect skin
i don't remember okay but she was pretty
she's back oh my gosh she's so cool
does she speak like a french time yes
this is her she's also on the tv
she's the cutest thing ever oh yeah i
know a horse that looks like that
what the [ __ ] yeah it was cute though
jeez learn compliments who's horse
which horse no my friend's horse well
she trains horses and then
the the horse had a haircut like her
that reminds me of the thing about your
mom and how he was trying to compliment
your mom's hair and then turning her to
a dog
yeah chihuahua chihuahua has beautiful
hair yeah but you don't come i mean
pomeranian
pomeranian
pomeranian's hair is off the book auburn
and amber and there's like oh
poofy hair the color the color of it
like how it changes
there's different colors of pomerania
well the ones that's in here you don't
compare people to animals it's like
reddish brown to dinosaurs
is this the one you're talking about
like a sauce yeah cherry glass yes
yeah no titties look like that no but it
i mean that's size i mean that's just a
different style
yeah come in all different shapes they
do and they're
so wonderful they're usually not that
geometric like they just come in
different sizes and it's something oh
there's some different shades titties
man that was the biggest surprise when
you start having sex with different
women and you're like oh
oh oh i would have not only had it with
people's juices
i'm a heterosexual male 1
sexual female and i also agree with you
yeah this is another sherry
shape yeah yeah you see look look look
lovely oh look
at this nice yeah you see now you're
gonna look at all the glasses and
compare them to you yeah
i might have a tester too okay you're
moving there how about this can you put
your boob in a mug
you know what i've noticed so romantic
on [ __ ] instagram
you know because everybody is out they
they know
women who have nice bodies know what to
do to get views right
but because it's so frequent in my
finder post i just don't care anymore
yeah
i've seen it so frequently it's like
skip skip skip
skip you know if you look at a lot of
their uh pages like they don't get that
much engagement
like how many followers like a lot of
them will have like a million followers
and they'll get like
three thousand likes these are too much
yeah
that's all that's all they posted
exactly
there's nothing to it it's like what is
this move on come on ladies
kind of like the story about the onions
i got it yeah but the onions though
though
that's why people be jacking off to the
onions now because they're like this is
a noodle yeah of all
different sizes i feel bad for this
onion company that got
flagged and taken down didn't do
anything the canadian seed
companies act are they sad
they say that rhyme they got they got
this notification because they
were they like it's not even horny 1.99
for these
these onions titties and then no onions
had seeds
i thought they had bulbs i didn't know
you had to advertise for onions
yeah like i just go to the store and i'm
like there's just one kind of brand of
onions that's just right there the one
that is in the store
you almost [ __ ] funny every recipe
has like a different type of onion
they're like okay you should get
i'm like no no which one's cheapest they
all taste like onions
can you tell the difference of onion i
mean there is but there's some sweetness
to some
honestly if i cook it down yeah i never
i can't tell the difference between the
vidalia onion the yellow onion or the
white onion once i cook it down it's
already sweetened
but then varietal of onion
you don't look at the brand right the
price i look at the product
what 10 cents i know what brand it sells
the onions to ralph i've never
ever known an onion brand i don't though
are better
raw i don't know it tastes better to me
bro so i know i know raw is different
right like if you have a vidalia onion
versus like a regular
thinking you're gonna say a vagina no no
no no perfect you're getting turned on
by these onions i think so like a
vidalia onion versus like a yellow onion
that vidalia onion like if it's raw it
tastes way sweeter
like i had that but once i cook it down
i can't tell so it's just raw red onions
good for your blood
maybe running is the red onions aren't
as sweet
that's true i used to know someone that
would just eat raw onion like an apple
and i'm like real
do you know remember
that was crazy i like onion raw so i
just did it i
just did it i didn't even spin the wheel
and get that one i just didn't know the
challenge that we had it was in my
backyard joe and i had a onion
in between us and we had to i forgot
what but i just remember that i think it
was like bobbing for
onions oh it was like bobbing for apples
but it was onions that was
some ridiculous [ __ ] yeah it was fun i
miss it yeah me
too you miss it for real you could do it
we could do it for patriots let's do a
patreon
like just does old school jk new stuff
it's like we watch it and you go okay
gio does it
jk do jk party stuff i take your party
yeah all right i'm down
bobbing for knives it
[Music]
[Applause]
did we do the watermelon eating contest
with you yeah i think you threw up and
daniel kron threw up i threw up i think
i threw him and he couldn't watch you
through it i think joel threw up too
right yeah
i don't know i think everyone threw up
yes i did happy birthday bunch of babies
oh babies
they're eating yourself brutal man with
the watermelon
oh i love watermelon my [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
yeah you better hurry up i think well
season's pretty much done
yeah now it's like probably like the
last week or two you should get
watermelons after that you've pretty
much done so
i feel bad buying pumpkins and then
carving them and then they just go to
waste
you're supposed to like get the seeds
though at least use those how do you
see bacon oh i have bomb seed recipes
yeah and then you could just bake them
and salt them and then
i love pumpkin seeds yeah yeah
okay you gonna do that you gonna make
some pumpkin scenes
uh if she sends me the recipe you ain't
doing [ __ ] dude i just wanna bet she do
it
in a story or it doesn't happen no i
know what you're doing and it's not
gonna work so
because of that i'm not gonna do it
exactly i knew it yeah
what does it sound like to you guys i
don't know write in the comments
you're nothing but a channel
[Music]
do
[Music]
you